let's talk about your injuries
what injuries to your understanding did
you sustain in this Collision
right now what your understanding as to
what happened to Terry in this collision
at the point I know
at least
I sustained a concussion
um and
um
that's the
two main factors I think and then
later on has some right leg and still do
right leg anomalies movement it just has
its own
idea and thinking where it needs to be
opposed to what I'm thinking
let's talk about how
your ribs
how your brain injury how that has
affected you okay
have things in your life changed
I'm like living another life now
let's focus
and go step by step different different
things physical wise
how how have you changed physically
since the accident
well
I can't ski anymore I was told
that if I did and had another crash
that I could wind up full time
full-time in a nursing home
the odds of that's very high
so no more skiing well and I I tried
I tried not to go back and
and I did ski a few more times by myself
just to see if I still could I had this
ungodly looking fluorescent red outfit I
bought a mips helmet to protect my brain
better and I thought I can do this I
really this is my love and joy I meet
friends I make friends I stay with them
the whole year there it's a year-round
activity and it's a life
lifelong activity
and so I
tried and I felt like I was skiing
through landmines just ridiculous looked
ridiculous all bright fluorescent red
wasn't thinking very well and then
and then I'd have to stop every 30 yards
and look back behind me to make sure no
one was right behind me
shot reaction
and
gradually gave it up just three four
times I think it was done okay
we go into more
do you have pains aches pains problems
your physical being
how are you
um
more careful person
um I don't take any risks and
more brain damage and
I'm not sure I understand your question
exactly have you had any kinds of
balance issues or headaches
um of course initially
that was just I my life was living in an
orange chair
sitting there
initially and sleep for 12 hours and
then
sit for half an hour and tell Carlene I
got a
go back to bed but to be fair it's not
like that anymore
no it's not
no
I
I had no anymore no it's not
let's talk about mentally how
how have
you seen yourself change mentally what
are some things that you've noticed or
difficulties that you've had mentally
many things I don't have the words
or the intelligence you're training to
explain you have lots of words I do I
admit it's just it's been a bizarre part
of this process as I never feel like
I've explained enough
there's I it's like big gaps I go I got
to start from the beginning and everyone
May recognize that by going through and
building a case and they don't know what
I'm talking about until I get to the
subject so it's everything is backwards
I'm building from the little things and
and then saying oh I'm talking about
apples you're going I had no idea
upside down and backwards communication
just feels like I I can't connect
and and so I keep trying desperately
trying
and and
[Music]
um
yeah personality changes is not
something I I just know it's different
things are weird you ever get lost oh my
gosh that was among the first signs when
I tried to get out and work on the Green
Team and um wait what's the green team
I volunteer for lots of groups I'm
probably a couple hundred years hours a
year at least I would think and green
team is one of those is significant a
large group of heavy heavy lifters who
pick up
[Music]
um
plastic and aluminum recycle after
concerts and USANA was the main one even
though we've done Liberty Park and it's
a group of maybe 15 people and we stay
up until one o'clock in the morning
picking that up up there and recycled
the last year I worked in 2015 23 tons
and it's not just walking 16 000 steps
on what I saw and it's bending and
scooping and lifting and picking up and
dragging a bag and it's hard work but
really really bonding with a lot of
people and doing that so that's what
that is so I tried going up there
and I and
usually I carpool
and that day I didn't
I'm usually the driver and so I parked
and went and did our thing and it's
maybe 12 31 o'clock and went back to the
car and headed home
I'm going the wrong direction I'm going
what's going on I've done this dozens of
times I was
lost now just to clarify this is since
the the ski crash right oh yes okay
in my instincts her always knowing where
North End is it's really been good
having grown up in the mountains it just
was instinctual
at night
I had no instincts anymore anyway and so
I had it just instinctually where I
thought supposed to be in wound up north
or south or somewhere else and that
happened a second time
had that ever happened to you before
this ski Collision I've never been so
reliable relying needing
maps and so
um
I I'm pretty sure I've lost visual
memory because it doesn't knowing those
turns and the house is where you turn
the streets should turn at
that feels like and I know a little bit
about that that feels like a deficit I
have that that doesn't I don't retain
that anymore I can be there a dozen
times and I still have to use maps to
make sure I get there